مشروعه رئيس لعبه مثيره في لبنان تصف
الواقع السياسي مثل ما تقول صحيفه
الجارديان البريطانيه وهي لعبه طاوله
يجتمع حولها اللاعبون وامامهم خارطه لبنان
وكل منهم لديه بطاقه مقلوبه امامه وعدد من
الاحجار البطاقه التي تحتوي على رسم لكرسي
عتيق على ظهرها ترمز الى النفوذ وتحدد
اللعبه باكملها وهي تمنح اللاعب الذي
يحملها الدوره السري اما كمصلح او فاسد
وتتابع الصحيفه ان لعبه مشروع رئيس لعبه
الفساد اطلقت في كانون الاول ديسمبر
الماضي واتاحت للناس فرصه ممارسه اللعبه
السياسيه في لبنان
والمهمه هي السيطره على الدوائر وفي نهايه
المطاف الفوز في الانتخابات الرئاسيه اما
من خلال الخداع او اللاعب النظيف لعبه
ومشروع رئيس معروضه للبيع في المحل
التجاريه في جميع انحاء لبنان وعبر
الانترنت وقد بيعت منها حتى الان 500 نسخه
وفقه الجاردن